now the second half of our interview
from Helsinki with the president had a
lot to say about the molar indictments
very interesting exchange on Angela
Merkel whether she or Vladimir Putin is
a better leader for their people and
more here it is you spoke with the
Russian president about the hacking of
the DNC servers
those indictments were announced just a
couple of days before you left on your
European swing what do you think of the
timing of those indictments well I don't
think of the timing as much as I think
of other timing Barack Obama was
president I was in problem I was a
president when this happened
Barack Obama was the president of the
United States when all of this this was
pre this was when I was getting elected
so I was being elected and I guess I
assumed this stuff all took place in
that area or before and he was president
and they informed him of it and he did
nothing and then after I won see he
thought Hillary was gonna win after I
won he said oh this is a big deal well
it wasn't a big deal as long as she won
so it's a disgrace and frankly it's a
disgrace what's happening to our country
would it be possible for you to direct
the Department of Justice FBI to take
possession of the server and have
assuming no government investigators
looked at it which seems to be the case
right now and get to the bottom of it so
as I've told you and the answer is
absolutely it is possible and maybe at
some point it'll be done but I've wanted
to stay out my Department of Justice is
the one branch the one group that I'm
very little involved in same with the
FBI
am I disappointed that they're not
looking at all of the crooked things
taking place on the other side like the
Pakistani man who left with these three
servers knew everything about shows know
everything debbie Wasserman Schultz and
I think you had three servers
I believe they even have them and they
don't want to use them for the DNC where
the server was never taken by the FBI
they went
in there and Podesta or somebody threw
them out of the office they should get
out of here and yet they go after other
people like there's no tomorrow
so I have purposely you understand that
I spoke to you about it before as they
said you're winning don't get involved
because I don't want have people accuse
me of anything so I've stayed very much
uninvolved but am I allowed to be
involved totally will I be involved
we'll have to see as it goes along I
mean right now people are finding out a
lot of things that they never thought
and in all fairness to the IG report it
was an unbelievable report except at the
end where they sort of tried to be
politically correct but when you talk
about biased has never been biased like
that now struck on the other hand was
you know that was total bias but that
report was a good report except for that
basic conclusion so finally on Europe
wasn't even bad having met with talked
to watch carefully on go Merkel in
Germany Vladimir Putin in Russia who do
you think from the perspective of their
countries does a better job represent
any interest again of their countries so
Angela was a superstar until she allowed
millions of people to come into Germany
that really hurt her badly as you know
she was unbeatable in any election she
allowed millions of people to come in
and when they came into Germany they
passed everywhere else and they went to
lots of other countries although Hungary
would not take any and a lot of people
wouldn't but what happened is it was the
great migration and obviously it's hurt
Angela very much I don't want to say
who's better who's not better but I will
say this she's been very badly hurt by
immigration very very badly so China is
a very rich countries you often say how
many refugees and immigrants does China
allow they probably none why is that I'd
say how about asking me about Japan how
about asking me about South Korea how
about asking me about a lot of other
countries that are very successful
turn those countries to allow millions
of refugees and immigrants to commence
pressure I don't even think the people
making the decision would want to waste
the phone call there's no chance check
out Japan ask them how many of you take
into the last 20 years you can count
them on your fingers
no it's different and well but wait if
the key to success as a country is
immigration let's say I'm not even
talking about giving success and it
depends on what immigration what's going
on but but you're asking me about China
and I get of Japan I added South Korea I
could add other countries also it is
virtually impossible I'll tell you what
Mexico has very strong immigration laws
you know Mexico wanted they could stop
this huge flow of people coming up from
different parts of South America
including Mexico and pouring into our
border our laws are so bad we have the
worst laws anywhere in the world we have
the worst immigration laws in the world
we don't have any law we have an
opposite to law and then on top of it
you have the right to separate children
okay so everything's bad but you have
the right to separate children it's it's
really disgraceful that the Democrats
aren't doing something about it because
we need their votes as you know so I
hope we're going to get enough
Republicans that we don't need them come
November but the Democrats we need their
votes we have as you know 51 and even
the 51 is not really there for obvious
reasons in the Senate and in the house
it's fairly close we need Democrat votes
in order to get it done and they really
just want to resist you know the whole
thing is resist right that's their big
thing we resist what do you get from
resistance but it's resist and obstruct
that's what they're all about it's the
only thing they're good about they're
not good politicians they've got
horrible policy but they're very good at
sticking together and resisting and
obstructing but that's hurting our
country but we'll get the immigration
laws changed President States thank you
for the conversation
thank you very much